americans are heading to the polls after
weeks of record-setting early voting
key battleground states could decide who
wins the presidential race between
president donald trump and
former vice president joe biden and some
states are just now beginning to count a
flood of mail-in ballots
meaning election results could take days
to be announced
we will make america great
again thank you pennsylvania thank you
pennsylvania
i'm running as a proud democrat but
i will govern as an american president
after an unprecedented campaign season
election day
2020 has finally arrived with both
candidates
offering dueling visions for the
nation's future
trump has pledged to be a political
outsider who will bring the economy back
while biden pitched himself as a
president who can unite a divided
country
months of preparations to hold a safe
election and tabulate early votes will
be put to the test
capping a race that has largely been
defined by the coronavirus pandemic
many states have already seen historic
levels of early voting
and more than two-thirds of responders
in the latest national wsj nbc news poll
said they plan to vote early either by
mail or in person
you two have a duty a duty to vote polls
indicate that supporters of biden are
more likely to have voted early
while supporters of trump are more
likely to vote in person
on election day get your friends get
your family get your neighbors get your
co-workers get your boss grabbing by the
tie say let's go boys
and get out and vote turnout will also
impact
other key races republicans are
defending their senate majority which is
up for grabs as
14 seats are now considered competitive
and democrats are working to hold
and expand their majority in the house
particularly in suburban districts
and keep an eye on the battleground
states that could decide the
presidential race
hello wisconsin we're back we're back
we're going to win
ohio one more day well hello
pennsylvania
[Music]
key states to watch include the western
states of nevada and arizona
the midwestern state of iowa southern
state's texas
georgia florida and north carolina and
perhaps most importantly the great lakes
states of wisconsin
michigan ohio and pennsylvania that's
where the candidates held most of their
events in the final hours of the
campaign
i've gotten to know this state very well
you know you're surprised you know
you're the one that put
us over the top you know that right
remember pennsylvania 2008 and 2012
you placed your trust in barack and me
now in 2020 i'm asking for your trust
again
while the most recent wsj nbc news
national poll shows joe biden with a
10-point lead
the race could hinge on states that
president trump flipped by
slim margins four years ago in 2016
trump won michigan by less than 11 000
votes
wisconsin by less than 23 000 votes and
pennsylvania by about 44 000 votes
put your ballot right over here and what
about results well we may get early
clues about the race
from florida ohio and north carolina
where polls close between 7
and 8 p.m eastern it could take days to
know the winner of states like
pennsylvania
michigan and wisconsin that's because
laws in those states say election
officials couldn't count mail-in ballots
ahead of this week
in some states ballots that arrive after
election day
may also be counted as long as they're
postmarked by november 3rd
the late tallying rules have both
parties preparing for legal battles
we should know the result of the
election on november 3rd
the evening of november 3rd
that's the way it's been and that's the
way it should be what's going on in this
country
i don't care how hard donald trump tries
there's nothing let me say it again
there's nothing that he can do to stop
the people of this nation
from voting in overwhelming numbers and
taking back this democracy